in today's it on your side we all want a
beef up for retirement savings but for
parents who had kids later on in life
and are still helping them out that may
not be a priority or for those still
paying off student loans but tonight we
take a look at changes that could impact
how everyone saves and withdraws money
from their retirement accounts
President Biden signed the retirement
savings Provisions known as secure act
2.0 into law shortly before New Year's
Day Brad Zucker with SMA wealth
management says these changes are
intended to help people maximize
retirement accounts the first major
change raises the starting age for
required minimum distributions the
required minimum distribution age now
increases to 73 years old and by the
year 2033 it will be at age 75 years old
this will help employees keep their
hands off their retirement accounts to
beef up that savings and provide future
income another big change is the
increase in ketchup contributions
effective now if you're 50 and older you
can set aside 7 500 a year to workplace
retirement plans instead of 6500 in 2025
if you're 60 to 63 years of age you'll
be able to add an extra ten thousand
dollars more per year above the standard
limit those parents that started having
families late in life and are super
supporting their kids are putting their
time and contributions on the back
burner here you can now beef up those
contributions and to be certain that you
are on track Zucker says in two years
the new Provisions will have employees
automatically enrolled in savings plans
and in just one year's time employers
will be able to make contributions to
workplace savings plans on behalf of
employees who are still repaying student
loans so for example if you made a 200
payment towards your student loan debt
balance your employer can match that 200
into a 401K plan
if you have to withdraw money from a
401k you currently face a 10 penalty if
you're younger than 59 and a half but
the new law now offers some penalty free
early withdrawal exceptions in cases of
terminal illness and people who have
been subject to domestic abuse